in the Middle Ages the Polish port of
Gdansk was one of the richest cities in
the world today it's a popular tourist
destination the kubicki restaurant on
the old port has existed for almost a
hundred years the former dance hall is a
Gdansk institution last year it was
renovated and the menu updated Damien
Mazeroski is the head chef he cooks
traditional cuisine but also likes to
experiment finally what time is not like
you do with all the shoulders rather
hearty but in gdansk poland biggest port
people have always been very familiar
with ingredients and spices from other
countries such as saffron soft vanilla
and cinnamon the kiss anemia bodacious
merchants brought them in from all over
the world windows template the mimetic
Ibaka smoothie was so actually Gdansk
regime has always been very modern with
ambition obtainable band only bartleboom
tell movies woof the city's market hall
and vegetable market are close by this
is where the chef buys many of his
ingredients he thinks it's important to
buy regional products
the fish comes in every morning fresh
from the Baltic Sea Mazeroski buys
herring for euromaxx ala carte
oh he gets his herbes from the fields
just up third gdansk herbs and spices
are an important part of his recipes
the chef has also discovered a small
family-run bakery near the restaurant
bread is still made according to
traditional recipes and there are no
artificial additives
let the Sigma patello the Russian red is
a very important part of polish cuisine
we eat it for breakfast lunch and dinner
that's why I wanted to have the best
thread because I middle and good bread
belongs to today's recipe pairing Tata
on polish black bread dummy and
Mazeroski cuts the fish into small
pieces and then prepares a special
marinade
Coco you dismiss logic of cashless
boumediene ivana after we chop it finely
we marinate the hearing the marinade is
a mixture of vinegar onions cloves red
pepper salt and sugar rush ago gene
let's go stays in there for about 12
hours oh boo considable bagel then dice
sour pickles and onions are added to the
fish I says mayonnaise a handful of dill
and a small bunch of chives all finely
chopped
all the ingredients have to be mixed
well Apple is then grated into the
mixture to go circles are formed from
the black bread with a ring mold and a
few drops of lemon juice go on to the
herring digha nikaya mr. go-to Vanya the
cake not be the same I cook very simply
but of course it shouldn't be boring
things that say is it'll be a nice thing
looks like I use simple ingredients in a
modern way don't wake up little dizzy
there are dishes with ingredients with
special types of mushrooms such as
truffles where customers immediately say
wow well the others well but it's much
harder to cook something interesting
with simple ingredients lost explain eco
animal totally Brazilian dummy and
Mazeroski uses them all to place the
herring Tata onto the black bread and
serves it with fresh herbs this
traditional but simple summer dish from
the Polish Baltic coast is now ready to
eat enjoy